hi everybody
um
so here I have a little talk on
ransomware detection I thought graphs
would be a cool way to do it
essentially to try and find new insights
to existing data
so let's go straight into it
it's just a little bit of background on
ransomware it's not really something new
um it originally came the first incident
2006 so that's almost 20 years it seems
to have been
facilitated by cryptocurrency
initially it was targeted that end users
like
your grandmother or someone like that
but in the last couple of years have
become more targeted at Enterprises
because essentially people making it
realized they could
what's seriously monetize it so just if
we look at some of the the ways that it
comes in
the top methodology is your fishing
attack some strange email or text
message there's also quite a lot of
any weather
type systems where they can bypass your
security or
exploit some vulnerability
um and any of you that have put weak
passwords it's probably not the best
idea
another interesting development is the
yeah
um runs more as a service we buy it's no
longer one group that is
engaged in the ransomware activity but
you'll have somebody gets into a system
and that's their kind of expectational
self that access to other actors so in
fact you don't need any technical
expertise you just kind of put the
pieces together and voila
just in terms of some data
I think it surveyed last week that came
out estimates 1.2 billion dollars in
um versus 2020 of 116 million dollars
that's quite a big increase the data for
2022 is
I think a little bit unclear there seems
to be some diversion of resources and I
mean perhaps that's related to
cryptocurrencies the client perhaps it's
diverted in Europe I mean it's just very
uncertain
so in particular I'm going to look at
the Conti group
which is one of the top ransomware
actors
um
and they've been estimated their
involvement in around
400 cyber attacks
and typically they're looking at around
25 million up to 25 million
um and what's interesting is as a
business they were able to generate
100 million a year which is
right quite impressive
so
if we take a small case study of an
actual incident that happened
so you've got the Irish National
Healthcare System
in May last year
basically the entire
technology infrastructure was brought
down
and
that were referred to appointments
getting canceled everybody's running
with
pen and paper
doesn't sound like a fun time to
have a pandemic
so essentially what was determined is
that
it wasn't your kind of more traditional
malware
which would be automated but essentially
it's human operated
and I think this is kind of the Next
Generation that we've been dealing with
um so it's it's a different type of
approach that's needed
so basically the the threat was they
were demanding 20 million if it's not
paid and they released 520 patient
records that just to prove that they
have the data
um ultimately they were able to get a
free encrypter which I think they were
very lucky
um and that's 70 of computers back up
and running
23rd of June
information that came out in the last
week
but the cost of the attack including
cleanup and just rebuilding all your
systems that are around 100 million
dollars
probably at least 10
000 data records
which is quite I mean these numbers that
are very round or but
I mean that gives you an order of
magnitude
there's some interesting government
reports on the nature and source of
these attacks
um there's just a link there at the
bottom you can
read more about
so if we look at the typical stages of
the attack
um and I think this is quite an
important slide because it sets up
what the focus of the talk is going to
be
so first you're going to have some kind
of
let's assume it's a fishing and what
that'll do is it's your entry into the
network
then there'll be a whole lot of
different types of activity
um things like your windows volume
Shadow copies
disabling various services
you can pretend to be a backup operator
that's kind of a handy way to evade
security
terminating Windows Services because if
you're encrypting things and you put
word open
then it's got a lock on the file so
that's not going to work
um and interesting there's some quite
Innovative encryption implementations
um now the problem with this is
typically if you take over the CPU
you're immediately going to notice that
you're here is unusable because it's
being used for
encrypt all your files
but the emphasis seems to be speed over
stealth
um just in terms of some of the other
success it was the top data leap leaker
207 gigabytes in a four month period
um various standard hacking techniques
living off the land using your existing
utilities DNS beaconings is a classic
way to try and detect I mean if they're
sending traffic
will pick up the use of things like PS
exactly
oh no it's really vital to understand is
your typical ransomware it's going to be
inside your network
for about a month and that's an
opportunity where you can try and detect
it and respond before you lose all
access to your
your data Conti seems to be slightly
faster and the data estimates about 15
days
so if we have a look at how exactly
the attack will progress
so here we've got a couple of stages and
for the purposes of this talk you're
simply going to assume that
[Music]
um
the
initial Ingress into the network has
occurred
most likely due to a fishing attack
so
I mean the first thing that they're
going to want to do is be able to
communicate back out to some kind of
command and control Beacon in this
instance there was a Cobalt strike
be a run dll 32
once they're inside your Network's going
to start to look around see where your
PD is
n't demand Discovery and then they need
to get beyond the user that they've
compromised and attempt to get some kind
of additional privileges so coval strike
has some things like this one named
patent impersonation
um and then ideally be able to move on
to the
actor directory
um
and once on active directory they can
copy into various share folders
and they might propagate throughout the
rest of the network
um
John I've got some extra extra steps and
ultimately right before the end is to
start applying group policies which will
automatically get rolled out across your
network so for example disable your
defenses essentially
um and in this example you had
approximately a two-day period
um so as you can see it's it's you need
to be quite quick if you're going to be
able to respond to it but there's
definitely a window of time
where
is an action
so in terms of some of the typical and
traditional approaches that are done
um
should have been developed what they
call indicate indicators of compromise
so here is an alert for a specific
friend somewhere that's targeting the
healthcare sector
um and typically the types of things you
can look for is IP addresses that are
being communicated with
various DNS systems domains that are
known to be malicious
what seems a little bit obvious is
phishing file names
I mean if you just can pick up the file
name and this is something that's been
um essentially automatically obscured so
it becomes more difficult to to prevent
um and and then in this example they're
primarily exe files has a lot of things
like JavaScript
images that have got malware embedded
PDFs that there's a whole range of
different
attacks and what's kind of interesting
is the actual commands
um so a lot of Powershell based things
so once you enter your windows Network
you can start to
do various fancy stuff and move to
different places
so essentially these indicators of
compromise are all out there and can be
downloaded but it's a very manual and
it's also you're looking for specific
things
so the idea with the growth-based system
is if you aren't looking for something
specific and you can see anomalies and
that's kind of where we're going to be
heading
so
in terms of the full gamut of different
thread actors out there they've got a
standardized approach and the the Metro
attack framework has attempted to
divide this into a different sections
and use different techniques at
different stages
um so essentially the idea is to build a
knowledge base of all the known
hacking techniques
um and come up with ways that you can
essentially detect that they're being
used in your environment
um
so drilling into this a little bit more
detail and doing a map against the Conti
in particular
um
so now you can see a
small graph of the kind of stages in a
particular attack
um that's divided into the
specific stages of the Metro framework
for the top level
so while you have
efficient
which will be assumed and that gives you
a
platform within the environment to
launch further attacks
and then we've got various
numbered techniques so for example if
you're in an environment you can have a
scheduled job run
or you can do some specific things
bypassing the user access control
creation of an account is something that
I mean if you don't know what accounts
are being
created within your environment this is
something you've got to be watching for
um t1140 is interesting because
you can no longer detect the actual exe
that's coming in there's a whole bunch
of obfuscation not just
changing the name but actually changing
the binaries by encrypting itself
um and ultimately at this stage what
you're going to have is those security
systems start to get disabled
Americans interesting is is when you're
pivoting through the network and you
start to obtain additional credentials
um there are a variety of attacks I mean
if you're present on a computer you can
pretty much see all the other accounts
that have been used on that computer
um
and you can see who's connecting to you
where they're connecting from
etc etc there's a whole lot of
techniques here but what's really kind
of quite concerning is
at the top right is when you're
attempting to gain access onto the
active directory so in this specific
instance we've got a zero logon which is
around 2020
there was a known one vulnerability
within active directory and more
recently
there's the magic where mobiliums
essentially a trick to
people can't fit anyone it's just like
doing a Jedi mind trick from active
directory
and once you interact with Derek you can
start to spread those files and
distribute files and we'll start looking
at the data around that
so in terms of the data source that is
being used what's kind of a little bit
difficult with security research is to
have data that's publicly available that
you can use to start to analyze the
problem
and there's a open threat research
project that has made data available so
that's what's been used as the kind of
thank you
basis of everything
I've used specifically an example of
att-29 that's been used which is around
200 000 rows it's primarily generated
from different Microsoft Windows log
files
everything from firewalls to Powershell
essentially a vital step in protecting
yourself is making sure that you do have
these logs available some of them need
to be enabled
and try to consolidate them in one place
so you can at least look at the data
um
now this Mystic pie is developed by
Microsoft actually it is the threat of
intelligence python security tools
and just having a quick look at the
capabilities
this gives you
essentially some really cool
examples of actual
threat indicators so in this query you
can do a lookup of t1021 and this is a
PS exact type technique
um and if we look at the types of
activity that's being generated by this
technique you have process access
execution of the pipeline
registry access and these are
essentially a count of the number of
events within the log file that's
generated by this particular attack
um
and moving on
if we start to look at an example of
country executing its
package one of the things it does is by
pumping the Cobalt strike Beacon it then
actually uses the PS exact service to
run various things across the network
so this this is broken into three three
stages basically first is
getting it put in the admin share
um
second stage is to attempt to escalate
your privileges
and get system access and in the last
step is then to create a new user and
once you've created a new user you have
supposed to do some different things
so if we look at the
the simulation Network what it looks
like
a set essentially you've got
four Windows computers
and you've got an active directory
server there are some Azure and various
other infrastructure
it's part of this network but it's not
really the focus of where the data is at
as we drill into it a little bit more
um
getting an idea of the types of data
sets we've got everything from host
names process that's getting executed
where it's coming from where it's going
to
what's interesting is there's some
overlap of different
data columns so it doesn't come through
in a clean way you can start to see it a
little bit better
when we look at a specifically process
named data
um
so the generated data has got
for example the username and the domain
Target name so you might have a subject
username and a Target username and then
certain log files
it gets enabled as different things
and this is quite relevant later on as
we'll get
I think what's what's important to note
here is the actual event ID which is
essentially Microsoft's recording of
what exactly the significance of this is
so just to get an idea
if you look in the right hand column you
can things see things like a logon was
attempted an account was successfully
logged on the token right was adjusted
so this looks like they were given
backup privileges
um and what's interesting is with
privileges you've been able to do
it's like an Innovative privileged
account so you can do more in the
network
um and right at the end you've got
their process was X
so exited so various things happening we
've run into that a little bit more
so if we have a quick look at what is
graph data
um
the basis under the core basis is it
loads and vertices
well nodes or vertices and edges
and essentially the way they're
connected to each other is what you want
to look
system
interesting mathematical properties you
can derive from it what we rely on
primarily in this talk is going to be
the closeness centrality so if you've
got a node in the middle
how closely connected is it to the other
nodes
and the mathematics behind it is
very straightforward however doing it
it's scaled you can automate a lot of
that using matrices
so in terms of the actual how do we
convert as a table of data into a graph
um
well I mean there's a couple of key
steps firstly
if you've got a foreign key that that's
an obvious thing that instead of being a
connection to another table which is
typically a join you can replace that
join with uh Eric pointer
um
yeah the initial approach I took was to
divide it into the four main sections
and the idea is anyone's going to have
an account
that account is going to run on a
particular computer and it's going to do
something I.E it's going to execute
something and the output of that is
going to be an actual event and that
that event is what we're going to look
at
um what's not included in this is any
network or Cloud related activity
and I think that that becomes quite a
lot more complex so it was wasn't
included in this
okay so shall we start to get what the
data is looking like that we're
extracting
um
so using the network X Library
you can see
if we look at the actual account name
and the host name
we have quite a few different hosts
we've got some things in common and one
of the
initial challenge you see is an account
called network service and this
typically runs on multiple computers
so what this means is by having a
duplicate account you aren't going to be
able to identify exactly who is using
that account because it could be on any
one of the computers
so if we start to make it more targeted
and combine
the hostname with
not just okay so
in terms of the who that is running the
process
the data has three primary Fields one is
account name two is the target username
and you've got the subject username and
depending on the log file it
a little bit different
so there needs to be some manipulation
so in the second diagram you can see by
combining the additional data points
he's starting to see a more
interesting graph
um drilling a little bit further into
that
the other side of it is you actually
want to be able to see what the account
of the person
but the specific account on a machine
and what is the actual event ID that
it's generating
so by starting to look at an account is
doing a thing
and what is quite helpful in the data
set is not just event IDs but there's
actually categories so for example you
could have a whole bunch of activities
relate that that have different event
ideas related to a process execution or
a python execution
um I mean that there's probably about 30
or 40 of these
categories in maybe a thousand different
events
so you're taking the graph and you're
getting more detailed but you're also
getting it more granular
so you're able to start to build a
picture
that is more meaningful
but what
what came out of the analysis was
there a whole lot of these event IDs
that don't actually have a category
assigned to them
um and in the middle of this graph
you've got the Nan
so this is just we don't know what
category it is
um
so
it needs more work
what's important just to point out is
that the computer sort of
on the right hand side
basically three quarters of the way to
the top right toilet New York slash
system
is the active directory controller so
we're definitely getting daytime
activity happening
and you can see this it's kind of
obvious from the first part of the graph
so once we start to clean up the data
and
do things like
gripping of suspicious accounts
identifying and known users
there were a bunch of accounts that we
weren't able to see who they were so
doing some further processing to make it
clear who exactly that was
and now here's what we're starting to
get is the output
once we've seen a few categories so they
are very clearly your main graph which
is your normal activity and there are
two separate clusters that is personal
abnormal activity and having exported
the actual relation so it can be seen
more clearly you essentially have a
security group management activity being
performed on pretty much every computer
or group in the
in the graph and on the other side
you've also got things being done with
Kerberos service ticket operations but
obscure but most likely is something
like are they able to
gain or not for us to access
uh so I think this is probably the most
interesting part
Drilling in I mean you can now see the
top
adjacencies
what I think is really interesting is at
the bottom we have W my activity and
this is exactly what Conti is using as
we showed right up front it's running
via wmi and these are some of the things
that it's being done on this wmi
activity is being run pretty much on
every
Network
also on the active directory New York
you've got a special logon
authorization policy change this is all
looking like some things should have
been updated
um now getting to put it in more
concrete format as opposed to just a
diagram we have to do closeness
centrality
um and you can see this quite clearly
maps with what is drawn in the diagram
um do a .01 as Kerberos service tickets
are
far away from anything else anywhere
0.06 and the majority of other
activities about 0.26
this is just a kind of a snippet of what
we're seeing
a little bit of code for how it was done
which is not particularly complex as a
NX closeness centrality function
I mean what is more tricky was
the joins and mappings and what have you
uh so just to look at the the kind of
conclusion
we were able to successfully identify
using an unsupervised graph suspicious
activity
what's noteworthy is the work parts of
your data limitations in terms of what
we're able to use it is a small Network
I think what's important to note is
but the graph is going to change over
time
and that's not something that we've
looked at so maybe having
chunk of the time domain is something
could be of interest
I mean I've also been reading quite a
lot about the computational intensity of
graphs which is a bit of a challenge
as the ex and this was 200 000 events
over four computers so there's quite a
lot of data in there
it also needs to be done quite a lot of
streamlining and sliding together and
all that kind of thing
I think what's interesting is a domestic
pie
um
is able to isolate individual events and
in this presentation I didn't go into
that level of detail but I think there's
definitely an opportunity to identify
those specific nodes
perhaps with a more supervised approach
where it gets interesting is there's
some initial work done on sequence
prediction so
when you're doing a an attack you've got
to go through certain stages and those
sequences are typically driven by
playbooks by the rental that the
ransomware actors have so you should be
able to do two things at one is Project
the next next thing they're going to do
but also use it as a fingerprint to
almost up identify the DNA of who the
threat actor is
and the last thing that I think is quite
important is how would you go about
productionizing this
and what you're going to need is some
kind of graph database that can do
streaming
there's a new database recently released
surreal DB I highly recommend you have a
look at it it was one of the top
trending
new open source projects on GitHub and
September a lot of promises
so I think
a couple of recommendations what can you
do to protect yourself
or one multi-factor Authentication
to some kind of identity Analytics
you've got to know where accounts are
being created when permissions why is
that happening
if it's happening on a phone it's only
something that needs to be looked at
and this brings us to point number three
Marshall to have some kind of process
you can't just have logging
if your alarm is going off what are you
doing about it
number four patch management I mean
every day there's another vulnerability
what's more difficult is inside your
open source libraries
I mean everybody's using them but
what is inside them and those
vulnerabilities inside of your code is
something that's
nothing looked good enough
vastly there's a report that came out in
the last couple of days by Microsoft
I've just included a link I think I
think it's really kind of worthwhile
taking a look at
um
and lastly that's it
it's my contact email if anyone
reach out to me have a chat
oh yeah
I think
yeah any questions
so I think it's easier if you say it and
then if you could repeat the questions
you only have one mic
presentation very interesting
so did you consider a exponential random
graph modeling
for your time series uh Arduino
random rap models
so the question was about exponential
random random graph bottles bottles
um I didn't get as far as working on the
time series component okay that's a bit
um
I hate to uh
something you already explained but I
didn't quite get a good sense of what
the links were between each of the notes
and the graphs
so the the nodes were
ultimately what we had was an account on
a computer
and it was generating an event so so
that was the actual link but the event
individual events were categorized to
reduce the the quantity of them so you
can start to see
um yeah so there's one account but it's
doing an event to another account
and so it would be an event that
One account that's generating in that
event
okay
okay so the account is now
generates an event which touched as
another account so so the second note is
the actual event category oh the second
note is it so you have basically
accounts and events
and the links are being recorded
grouping them yeah
so you mentioned kind of some
unsupervised machine learning techniques
have you thought of any supervisor
data sets
yeah just any have you thought of any
supervised machine learning companies
in in terms of supervised machine
learning techniques
I wasn't looking at techniques in
particular
but I think the fact that there's a
library that can extract the
kind of type of event
would enable you to automate it across
large sets of data
so the supervisual would be the ability
to automate what is the
type of attack
any other questions
so you can hear me so
um thank you for the talk very super
cool
um I noticed that you had to abstract
away a number of the layers probably
because of data size so at the event
category level and also at the account
level so ideally I would think that you
would want the graph to be ridiculous
all of the computer is talking all the
computers talking to all of the people
talking to all of the events without
anything being abstracted and that's
your best chance to catch zero day
I think for computation is a problem so
have you thought about that connected of
a graph and maybe started chipping away
at the bigger problem
yeah and just being able to holistically
connect all the things rather than
losing information to every abstraction
layer
um
okay so so the question was have I
thought about
expanding it out to essentially behave a
full graph which is where ultimately it
should be to be fully effective
and I would say I had two problems
with that I mean the first was
the ability to visualize it
um and I think Network X has
it's a little bit tricky to get the
visualizations to come out nicely and
with even with this graph it's starting
you can't see any of the detail so there
are a couple of other tools out there
that do a better job of that
and that was part of the reason
I think the other reason is I think as
you get
deeper into that kind of having a bigger
graph more detail you're going to need
more data for things to come out
and this was using a limited set of data
I think that what you're saying is
exactly where we need to get to
and then you also start to need to have
a proper graph database that you can use
[Applause]